and we're going live yes social media
[Music]
people love you too oh well I've we're
doing it right now so we we've uh God oh
what's the word gawked what's the word
when you hold over someone's body
sure well dude you got jack'd you want
to being skinny to shredded yeah yeah
you're pretty serious about MMA training
man it's really just about like the
lifestyle you know I mean you're a
martial artist so you know freaking the
mind in the body and the soul go
together so yeah these things I'm
learning about them I'm I'm able to put
them all together you can't be a
complete person until everything is
together so you know spiritually I've
already ascended above my peers now I'm
taking my body up there how do you do it
spiritually through that giant juggle
weed you got a table exactly yeah
yeah for the focus only listen Wiz
brought literally like a mason jar held
would we yeah yeah yeah it's like
halfway full extrange that you like yeah
I smoked the KK Khalifa kalisch oh you
got your own [ __ ] yeah yeah absolutely
cuz I got tired of smoking are different
types wheat it's like a drink you know
what I'm saying alcohol people only
drink dark liquor whiskey yeah I only
smoke cocaine only if you mix it up
though you'll get a big hit right you
switch it up to somebody else's stuff
you like whoo daddy's not not ready for
it my head will go crazy yeah like I'll
really fill it you'll see me like over
in a corner stone okay that's it that's
the weird thing about weed right it like
you you get used to a certain strain
yeah like I'll get physically like ill
if I don't smoke my strain I'll get
ready those real coughing yeah yeah I
need ten heat KK Wow
yeah yeah how much you smoke a day
probably ounce
like a coin gin the cool about you I
don't smoke that much me no I got joint
more like a jointed Amalie yeah I would
think that you were like just getting
stoned all day I get stoned all day when
I don't have [ __ ] to do catch you
but if I have too much [ __ ] to do I get
stoned all day that [ __ ] doesn't get
done you said you like blitz yeah boys
because a little tobacco gives you like
this little extra high yeah I'm glad you
admitted it yeah no people who smoke
blunts they they they don't some of them
they don't know that their tobacco ink
and they try to mask it and say no you
know it's leaf it's like no bro you like
tobacco it's tobacco with weed yep it's
a like a combo high it cuts it yeah I
like it before I go on stage it's my
favorite before I go on stage that's
just a little pickup hi
I'm happy how legal weed is these days
because it's like I would I must learn
how to spring concert yesterday and I
would feel like [ __ ] back in the day
walking in there smelling like but cuz
he goes to private school it's
reflection on him yeah so it's like you
know you got the weed head dad blah blah
blah another thing but it's like
nowadays I should have kool-aid no one
cares nobody gives a [ __ ] yeah I've seen
it happen because I have a 22 year old
daughter but I also have an 11 and a 9
year old uh-huh and with the 22 year old
when she was growing up it was all weird
weird it was like if you were you were a
loser for smoking weed lay dates you
know say yeah people coming over your
house you got weed at the house yeah but
parents get weird I live like right up
the street from the school so I'm
getting real technical with it I think
yeah I'm in a school zone like
legitimately yeah like I could be not
here right now incarcerated for real
that lady they locked up today in Dallas
did you see that [ __ ] no no a lady a
grandmother they locked her up because
she had CBD on her oh yeah she was a
Dallas Airport
it's not even psychoactive and I think
she had the oil like first skin right oh
hey it's just ridiculous she's old lady
old lady needs it for arthritis that's
right my wife's mom uses it for
arthritis it's great solder [ __ ] this
[ __ ] my my daughter called my ex baby's
mom she's still my baby's mom but she
has another baby on the way
in her new relationship but she's able
to take CBD during her pregnancy to help
her her nausea and all that's yeah it's
like why would you hate on CBD bro no
it's amazing this [ __ ] is my friend's
son has some seizures he has
some sort of epileptic scene get some
CBD it's gone
is it everyday it doesn't have him
anymore that's amazing it's incredible
it's so good it's almost you feel like
you're lying
what does so many different things right
that when you talk about weed you feel
like you're lying yeah I mean like these
days in this day and age I was just
telling somebody the other day smoking
pot is going to be old school like you
know I mean we're still going to do it
but it's totally moving towards just
ingesting it yeah I've been it on and
all that [ __ ] sprays
yes scared of it and it works like yeah
like [ __ ] like the thing about the
animals don't puts you in a weird place
we get too much yeah yeah I've seen
people melt down yo edibles are crazy so
I got a homie who just took a THC pill
yesterday and he was talking about types
of [ __ ] like really I should knocked him
how he's probably still asleep
yeah the edibles [ __ ] you up you do
edibles yeah I do but yeah I've had some
bad experiences but like someone really
not bad but like like completely lost
could touch with this dimension Dale you
know what I'm saying yeah like I had a
friend of meet THC pills yep and I was
taking him out of party once it was a
party for jujitsu tournaments well
because it was a jujitsu tournament and
then there was this party afterwards and
by the time the pills had kicked in I
have no idea how much was in there
because it was like some handmade [ __ ]
that this guy stuck together himself a
little capsules that it was as high as
I've ever been in my life to the point
where I wasn't even seeing people I was
seeing like a two-dimensional cutout of
the person and then behind them I was
seeing like their true intention
hi [ __ ] I was talking this one dude and
he was just he's he was a high-level
jujitsu guy was really was really odd it
was a very strange feeling I got talking
to this cat
and then um like a month later he was on
the run for rape yeah he raped some
woman and then he escaped and then he
was out so addicted to jujitsu the story
was that he started training again with
a fake name but he was like this high
level black belt there's only that this
especially back then when this happened
is like the early two-thousands there's
only a certain number of high level
black belts that are running around
right so he put on this fake Brazilian
name and started training in like the
Pacific Northwest and then but he's
strangle in black belts and everybody's
like what the [ __ ] is who is this guy
some people ask face is someone took a
picture of him they go that guy's wanted
for rape oh [ __ ]
I remember talking to him on these THC
pills being like like some there's some
wiring that's not correct oh [ __ ] yeah
damn duh that's in whoa yeah
THC pills and yeah the exposed thing
yeah they do bro I didn't mushrooms in
it exposed a lot yeah yeah you just
wrote yeah yeah yep I [ __ ] with
mushrooms because that's what happens
with me when I was on mushrooms I was
able to see people's true intentions
yeah I was being a rapper and [ __ ] like
that you know you'd be having to peel
back the layers layers and layers and
layers and I was trying to peel my own
layers back just for my own Shore
personal every man I ended up yeah yep
and I ended up being like backstage
somewhere and I was like [ __ ] I was like
I'm around all these people and I really
see their true intentions and I was like
I see what crowd they are and it was
like I felt like I was separated you
know what I mean it was like I was on a
boat all the way out here and they were
all on all on an island partying and I
was like damn yeah I could see what's
going on over there but it was cool like
I do mushrooms every now and then I
don't [ __ ] with it all the time I
haven't done them in like three years
because they help you see [ __ ] like that
so it's like for me I'll take that
experience and I'll just live with it
you know I don't need to keep going
through
like you probably seen that dude was
like oh [ __ ] now I know people who are
rapey as soon as I see him I knew he was
dangerous like he was a legitimately
dangerous person but not the same bro
not just a trained killer but he was
dangerous like the way thought about
things that's why there's people like
that out there yeah yeah I mean you you
you you don't know until you experience
it and that was a mild experience
compared to most people's owners psychos
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] I know I know
just probably in fighting too that's why
I feel like more people need to like
smoke weed and train I think so too
because it balances it is great man
alleviate Saul that [ __ ] with the most
people
mmm-hmm but there's gonna be some dudes
just like that guy that are just they're
just out there yeah it's taking it to
that level like yeah yeah yeah that's
crazy
when you think about the world of
fighting and competition I mean you're
dealing with people that are taking the
biggest risks they don't have to do that
this is like the choice I could get a
job the choice is I want to get a job
trying to [ __ ] up other people who have
a job trying to [ __ ] up people the
killers the trained killers just going
after each other right right and when
you're around those dudes one of the
things you one of things you realized
very early on you that you can have your
preconceived notions about them being
like like mean people violent people
right they're people of character yes
sir you have to have extreme character
to pull off what they do yeah yeah
there's some of the best people I've
ever met my life for fighters yep yep
they're they're a different breed of
human being yeah they chose that path
they chose it yes no one's forcing them
we're not in war right
they decide to go and do that and that's
why it's so exciting to watch right
right because you know that they're
putting everything on the line right I
look at it like like you said they chose
that so you don't become an athlete to
choose to fight you know what I mean
like and a lot of them are really like
you said smart and they're technical and
especially how the sport is developing
these days because people don't want the
long-term damage but they want to still
like you know what I mean go hard so hmm
they're coming up with [ __ ] all types
of ways to do this [ __ ] and it's like at
the end of the day you have to be
creative or you
have to have some type of something up
here you know I mean you're not just
fighting to be fighting you know right
so yeah I think they all go in for the
same reason you know they're trying to
find out if they can do it right and
then they have a just a drive to prove
that they're the best right I was just
talking to somebody the other day about
that it was like a crazy argument
because they were saying how fight fans
are just there for knockouts and I was
like you definitely have your knockout
fans like those probably the people who
pay the most you know I mean it's like
but I was like you got to give credit to
a lot of people who understand fighting
and love it and are viewing it for that
aspect there's like you know Luna Park
you watch football like a lot of people
played football and you know wish they
could have been that person on the field
they just haven't you know I mean yes I
was trying to explain so I was like it
was a huge crowd of people who actually
know about this [ __ ] who are
knowledgeable and those people supported
as well it was weird yeah I feel you are
know exactly what you're saying
there's some people they just want to
see people get beat up and some people
that want to see Floyd Mayweather duck
punches right you know one of the best
things about Floyd Mayweather and Canelo
wasn't that Floyd beat Canelo um he out
boxed him right but he showed this level
of defense right if you're a boxing fan
Yulin Jesus Christ like he knows
everything that's coming yeah he's
always in the right angle he's always
one step ahead and that's why he's so
good
yeah his defenses the boys only been hit
like a few times in school career really
hard see like Shane hit him a couple
times was it my Donna Donna hit him
really hard when they [ __ ] like save
the clip and play it over think about
other boxers how much they get hit I
love watching that I love watching
someone who could move like that right
right like my favorite fighter to watch
the UFC was Mighty Mouse mm-hmm not just
because he was the best pound-for-pound
fighter on the planet but because he was
not getting hit right he was
occasionally someone would tell like
John Mayer got tagged him with straight
limb occasionally some guys hit him but
most times things are just grazing yeah
thanks for getting block right right if
he gets hit he's moving right it's a
he's a puzzle right if you're a fan of
martial arts you want to see the master
of the puzzle exactly yeah hell yeah and
I don't I don't count them people out
and I wouldn't [ __ ] sit in front of a
dude and let him just be like oh yeah
everybody will see knockouts like nod
like it's not like that family I think
everybody likes both things though yes
like when you get like Arturo Gatti
versus Micky Ward you ever see that
fight it was a trilogy of [ __ ] wars
between these two guys that were not
champion they were they were like one
step below at the time of their career
being like championship level right so
they weren't like in threat of fighting
for the title no one thought they liked
Floyd was better than both of them by
far right but what they were doing was
showing the two guys that are similarly
talented can put on like the most
entertaining fight in the world it was
incredible crazy back and forth it back
for I like watching that too yeah yeah
you know yeah I want to see a good fight
me personally I like watching both
things I like watching someone just
completely willy pep somebody jig just
like Pernell Whitaker used to do yeah
he's a great boxer he couldn't hit him
no he was so slick nope you know and you
can only do that for so long like in any
sport and you know he'd be at the top
for so long watch those performances
when those guys were at the top that
shows you what's possible hell yeah and
this is good to see somebody like master
their craft - yeah cuz you see them come
up like you watch them bi and then it's
like they become the [ __ ] and it's like
oh yeah
you know mean I've seen this do like
start from just being okay and now he's
just [ __ ] [ __ ] up you see them learn
you see them develop you know that stuff
is fun like you grow with him that's a
good combination of getting to the
bottom of [ __ ] is weed and martial arts
yeah yeah that's a good combination 100%
it really is I do like a lot of my
thinking is just from like after I
trained I just sit there and just think
about nothing but you know what I mean
you know ideas come to me how to deal
with situations you know what I mean
because it's just I don't know it just
happens like that just flows yeah yeah
it flows and I think like the training
helps you get all the [ __ ] off your
back right hell yeah
right yeah yep especially for me too
cause like I party a lot and I'm in a
studio till like 5:00 6:00 in the
morning and I'm drinking and stuff like
that so to just be going down that path
and doing that every day bro I look
crazy I feel crazy you guys I have to
get that off of me like I don't mean you
know that I mean that's why your gym is
crazy but I need to do something like
that for myself it's nice to have at
some point like that's how I look at you
like the og so it's like I'm not gonna
go do it tomorrow like hey everybody
build me a gym but you know eventually
that's the goal when I look back I'll be
like I seen Jose Jimenez that's what me
dude you train hard I've seen your
videos yeah well I get to work you work
out it unbreakable yeah yeah your spot
yeah that's a great gym it's a really
good gym Jay Glazer yeah he owns that
spot there a very impressive place he
put together in awesome place yeah yeah
it's cool the team there is good like I
said it's not all about like just
fighting and being you know the biggest
baddest meanest [ __ ] like they
really taught me about my body
mm-hmm that's what they do they teach
you there whatever your goals are they
bring you you know up to that speed so
it's like I'll wait like 140 pounds ever
since I got out of high school and I was
like [ __ ] I gotta gain some weight and
they helped me out and doesn't snoop
train there too yeah there's this video
snoop sparring he's sparring daniel
Sarafian yep Daniels [ __ ] crazy at
least yeah I know that guy he'll have
all his fights before he's a tank
he is crazy like has a tank nuts his
thing is like you know I gotta get hit
I'm like all right Daniel you know he's
got to get hit the weak himself oh yeah
Wow there's his barn with him yes Luke
was going at it so he's trying to take
him out
dude Snoop throws some good shots them
right there yeah Snoop skills he really
does some glad Daniel ducked that one oh
yeah I mean oh I guarantee you snoop
that's funny right a lot of people their
fist fight oh yeah he's tall as [ __ ] to
look at a team like that look at those
arms
yeah
look at that it's new so that was so ha
ha that's Sarafian that guy's a tank
mm-hmm yeah he fought in UFC for a while
he's still fighting still active yeah I
think he's in Brazil right now using
yeah he was working at the gym for min
and and he I guess he chilled out yeah
it's it's anyway my point was the videos
it's nice to see cuz you train hard like
watch you do muy Thai hit the path so
you're really putting it work on this
sir yeah yeah it's everyday thing it's a
journey like you know I mean Tyler Ernie
Ernie Reyes is my oh [ __ ] I got sunshine
right there that was Stu
he was teaching me some stuff while I
was early do I suck right there oh do
you our sparring right there with one of
the greatest muy Thai fighters if not
the greatest of all times yeah that dude
was super tight he's amazing yeah he's
really good his videos like highlights
yeah you ever see that jumping left
switch kick yeah knocked I do that with
yeah yeah yeah yeah outstanding crazy
cake so how cool is that man you you're
sparring yet with one of the greatest of
all time as far as [ __ ] mmm it's like
those people like you know about
fighters did the majority said when you
meet them they they're cool as hell yeah
so to meet him and him not wanna whip my
ass when I tell me like hey you look
goofy sit down he's like showing me [ __ ]
that I could use later so it was cool
well the Thais have a really interesting
way of sparring some of them do they
play right they don't hit each other
full blast mm-hmm they're like tap and
they'd laugh around and joke around
they're just developing their timing
yeah because they fight so often yeah
John Wayne Parrs a friend of mine from
Australia multiple time world champion
mm-hmm and you know he would talk in
depth about how they would play they
just play they just hit each other just
slap each other a little bit and you
like that way they understand the timing
of it but they never worry about it they
don't get hurt mm-hmm and they can do it
all the time a really smart way to do it
yeah but you'll see guys like Sarafian
he's capable of doing that
so he could spar with a guy like snoop
or a guy like San Choi could spar with a
guy like you and you can play with you
right everybody just have a good time
it's fun at the end yeah
super-fun yeah yeah how are you
definitely seen that a lot like more
Instagram and even with my trainers will
do it like me or he was just doing that
yesterday was like developing the time
and of the cakes where it's like you
kicked me I kick you I can't you you
kick me I kick you twice you kicked me
three times I kick you once like you
said just playing around yeah and like
when you got a good sparring partner you
take care of each other exactly don't
hurt yeah but there's no ego involved
and the ties they do like knees though
they don't need a [ __ ] out of each other
like it looks like kind of hard but
they're just making their bodies harder
like you say for later because yeah
they're used to it
a lot of times they'll slap each other
with the side of their leg too right
that really drive the knee in yeah
they're just slapping each other a
little bit but that's it's obviously
it's very effective like they figured
something out you got some crazy cakes
thank you yeah I seen what was it a side
kick that you did probably turning side
kick yeah yeah you got to teach me that
I'll teach you that yeah I'm with the
forum because I'm learning just a
regular psyche like a slide you know go
to like a Taekwondo school they'd be the
best at showing you how to do it I'll
definitely show you how but yeah if you
need a place to Train find like a really
good Taekwondo school mm-hmm because one
thing Taekwondo has some things that you
know won't work in MMA if you're adding
takedowns and punches to the face but
because they don't punch to the face in
tournaments and you get used to doing
crazy kicks crazy yeah so they have a
lot of weird a lot of weird leg
dexterity stuff and if you get good at
that stuff I think that's a good I had a
kid that wanted to fight I would say
let's just do some yoga Shen or some
Taekwondo first just do some karate
something we you develop in leg decks
there yeah hailey then as you get a
little older then movie into more time
right sorry you could do both things
mm-hmm because if someone's caught you
when guys are like constantly chopping
at the legs they never really develop
the kind of spinning kicks that guys do
what they don't kick the legs right
those are the guys have developed the
best spinning kicks cuz it's so easy to
chop the legs and effective chop the
legs out mm-hmm so a lot of those
techniques don't really get dialed in to
the level that they get dialed in from a
Taekwondo guy
mm-hmm because they can't kick each
other in the legs right right
it's kind of a dumb way to fight because
you should kick the legs but at the end
of the day it allowed them to develop
some crazy [ __ ] and a lot of weird
spinning stuffs guys are so fast and the
powers insane yeah yeah cuz it's all
moving torque and bull crazy [ __ ] it's
just it's hard to develop right hard to
develop those tits like a lot of posture
and you got it really you got to be
balanced then you got that knee is
everything right you got a dustin how
you aim it so it's like when you're
spinning or even if you're just standing
there you have to have correct posture
and be able to do a couple kicks like
you says like a lot to go on
coming at somebody spending glisten
doing all types of [ __ ] so it's
different for show it's really good for
your balance to do that as a young kid
and learn some other [ __ ] later right
you'll have balance yeah that's what
I've seen when you kick the [ __ ] out of
that [ __ ] was like you like really
balanced and straight like you know that
I mean the the tech because a lot of
people I you might be strong as [ __ ] but
you can see technique right right and
this if you do the [ __ ] over and over
and over really perfect it that's
different than just being able to throw
a strong kick
yeah me yeah techniques everything and
that way in jiu-jitsu it's that way and
then I'm it's got to be that way of
music be that way in everything yeah
definitely man I'm in a studio like all
the time practicing like I could write a
song before this interview is over
but that's because I practice you know
it's not because like I'm the most
lyrical person in the world it's like I
just [ __ ] rap every day like it
should come easy so but when you write
do you write things out or do you do you
do it out in your head like I know jay-z
supposedly doesn't write anything right
it just keeps it all in his head yeah
yeah incredible it's awesome that he can
do that right it's kind of insane yeah
yeah yeah I have I have different
processes so like for me I kind of
melodies like I'll sing and I'll rap so
it's a lot easier for me to just have a
melody in my
head and make up the words as I go but
if I'm writing lyrics like writing words
down where I actually rap it that's what
I'm gonna use the paper you know but
there's different ways to do it because
honestly this is what my studio setup
looks like it's like a chair the mic is
right here I don't go in the booth for
anything in my engineer sitting right
there so it's like we're coming up with
it as as we go I'll take a little break
just write something down and then I'll
just jump jump straight back on it you
know what I mean so there's different
techniques though because a lot of times
sometimes I won't write [ __ ] I'll just
go and just make it up and just keep
going keep flowing or there's times
where I could just lay a melody and then
write the words to it later so it's just
different you know ways to approach it
so you just do it based on however you
feel that day mm-hmm whatever the track
really calls for it's like if if the
song is something that I get instant
inspiration on my oh I'm gonna knock it
out right now or if something I want to
live with for a little bit I'll just do
as much as I'm happy with it at that
point and then move on to the next thing
come back to it later and just make sure
everything is fresh I like to keep
everything fresh keep it fun keep it
loose and I don't really overthink
anything if it's not there then I just
go go away from it and find something
that's more fun yeah that's a it's a
beautiful freedom to be able to do that
you know yeah you obviously picked the
right [ __ ] job I swear like you know
it's it's a it's work because I I'm
always looking for what's next you know
what I mean for the fans for the
listeners for the people who supported
me all the way to this point like okay I
gotta push myself I gotta do what's next
I got it has got to be crazy you know I
mean I got a son he's six so it's like I
gotta impress him I can't have him just
listening to a whole bunch of other
rappers and not my music so it's like
yeah yeah it's uh you know it is an
interesting responsibility you have
right yeah yeah and a guy like you
becomes famous it's an interesting like
you have so many people that want you
know and I think we need to call it a
different thing other than
work yeah cuz it's like there's work
like [ __ ] I work for UPS right yeah it's
cool they're good good benefits and
that's work right what you're doing is
like you love it yeah hell yeah you know
when you love something almost we need a
better word yeah for sure that's the
same word as working at McDonald's the
same word we work a market word would be
need a better word like a passion
project like being able to do what you
want to do exactly whatever that thing
is yeah yeah no I believe that that's
that's a good point because it's not the
same work it's not the same thing
no it's not the same thing we need to
put in the work yeah we're a [ __ ] job in
your life you know what that is that's
work yeah we put in the work we've done
that but saying I'm going to work when
you're going to do something you love
you're excited about
yeah it's we need a better word then
that's why I think that's true that's
why people get pissed at me there's a
hundred girls there I had a punch in
just like you yeah in that sense the
world is just not fair okay you know
some people's jobs are not the same I
mean [ __ ] you stop and think about how
fortunate you are
yeah yeah yeah I thank God every day bro
beautiful all the time because it is it
is a blessing I'm literally like last
night I'm like writing a song and the
only problem that I had was like a
girl's ass was right on me I was like
baby like I'm enjoying this as much as
you are but I got it like physically
right so I was like your ass is like I'm
moving my arm around like you can do
that but just right there you know I
mean like no and I started thinking
about something like wow these are my
problems like yeah that's cool just a
little bit of discipline that's amazing
yeah I'm cool with that yeah for sure
that's amazing yeah yeah yeah and the
song got rid so we beautiful yeah yeah
job got done
yeah this is another word right
that's not Newark you were not working
you're working obviously you're working
at it but it needs a better word a
nobler word the fans will come up with
the word for sure they're way more
creative yeah that way more time on
their hands
yeah I think they will they'll figure it
out okay and we'll report back for sure
I just make sense there's no way it's
the same thing mmm it can't be
not hell not for show nope yeah and
that's why I always tell people when
people always try to think down they
always try to think man that's easy for
you to say or not everybody can make it
yeah you're right not everybody can
truth but maybe you can right woody what
does that mean not everybody can
everybody can everybody's gonna do
everything nobody's gonna walk to the
top of the hill that's the thing
some people gonna stop halfway I can't
do it that's the thing yeah
people limit themselves in a crazy way
they're like oh yeah everybody can't do
it it's like you says I know everybody
can't do it
it takes a lot you know I mean you gotta
[ __ ] go through the [ __ ] to get it
but when you get there it looks awesome
right yeah
yeah I mean it's whatever it is yeah you
know try to figure it out and go do it
oh yeah hell yeah Mike you said the top
of the hill looks great but some people
settle for the middle yeah and they get
mad if people get to the top that's
[ __ ] you know they get mad at
the at the top man there's no one who's
like you doesn't work hard right so
that's the myth right that's the thing -
it was like main it so again the wrong
word for it right
passion hard whatever it is right I mean
you don't a tattoo craft maintaining it
is there's an art to that right because
you work so freakin hard to get to where
you're at and then you get there and
it's like aw [ __ ] what do I do
like there's no rest there's no rest
everything that was acceptable before
becomes unacceptable because now you're
up here
you know I mean so it's like yeah you
have to you have to you have to pick
your shots and like you know I'm saying
can't really like just go crazy like you
did back in the day so there's an art to
it you know what I mean and that's how
you really maintain and stay in that
spot and even level up
so do you consciously think okay balance
out enjoyment with things that I have to
do to stay discipline 100% yeah 100%
that's a very smart way of looking at
yeah yep 100% like those there has to be
a balance of each because it's like all
right now I'm at this new level like
whether I want to behave like this or
not I put myself here I worked hard now
I'm with these elite [ __ ] so
this is the this is how I have to act
because I'm not down here anymore I
worked from here to get here so what
happens you balance you put things into
place you do a little bit of this and a
little bit of that instead of a lot of
that you know I mean and you just pick
your shots and it's like you're gonna
get everything in the end this is how
it's just planned and how it's supposed
to be but you just piece it together
just a little bit differently like I
just turned 31 well damn I'm about to be
32 that's young too a lot of people
that's old to some people as well but
for me it's like there's a whole new
mind state you know what I mean and I
feel like through my 20s I was actually
like a [ __ ] teenager and like now I'm
an adult so now I look at things a
little bit differently it's like you
know I was really a kid this is how you
behave as an adult for the rest of your
life and it still involves a whole bunch
of partying and having fun but the
business gets handled and things get
approached totally differently that's a
balanced way of looking at it man I love
it mm-hmm enjoy it this other think to
like people have to understand to to be
someone like you to be a very successful
rapper mm-hm and to not expect you to
live the way you talk about all the time
right so ridiculous right right like you
don't think you he wants a party he's
talking about party
I think he wants a party party this is
just an act yeah yeah
it's weird right it's crazy as [ __ ]
because people they want you to be you
they want me to be myself right they
want a party they don't want to take
shots they want to smoke weed they want
to stay up all night yeah why is that
bad it's nice so many people want to do
it but it gives us image in some
people's minds and like frivolous life
mmm
frivolous thinking Marty mm-hmm what are
you doing drinking and smoking and then
they come around and do the same thing
because they want it it's like I have
like a weird place in life where I think
I'm like the key to a lot of [ __ ]
because it's like if you want to enjoy
yourself I'm a guy I mean I don't I mean
it's like oh man I'm just [ __ ] gonna
live through it where it shows up he's
gonna light the joint it's gonna be
amazing if you want to [ __ ] be
professional like especially when will I
do because there's a whole lot of
rappers who like on business you know I
mean they're not thinking like that
mm-hmm so for those guys I'm their guy
like they look at me like where's has
his [ __ ] together like he really handles
his business he talks to people he shows
up he does this he does that so to be
the party guy and the business guy it's
like amazing you know what I mean it's a
it's a lane that I kind of carved for
myself but it's me in real life so it's
like that's the only thing I have to do
is really just completely be myself just
be 100 [ __ ] show up do my business
thing tell people do the right thing and
[ __ ] lie to joy that's it that's a
crazy business sir I'm good I'm straight
like that that's amazing Mia people
listen to this apart Wow
mm-hmm he could beat yourself for a
living for a show bro his blessing it's
a blessing I had John Witherspoon on
yesterday with his son JD okay you know
pops with his phone yeah yeah and that's
basically what he is he's one of the
funniest [ __ ] human beings that's
ever lived right and just keep a camera
on them just keep a camera up that's the
holes Oh
in real life he's amazing he's so funny
he's legit my face was hurting the other
day like the cheekbone muscles they're
like ah he probably got some crazy ass
stories oh yeah that [ __ ] been
in the game forever
yeah and he's that's who he is he got
paid to be who he is and figured out how
to just be who he is yeah all the time
yep it's the same damn bro yeah it's not
limited to one or two of us right now
there's a bunch of different paths
that's the Copa yeah yeah oh yeah so how
many years you've been trained in
martial arts now this is my second year
Wow
yeah only two years that's amazing I
gained what 35 pounds I'll pull up a
video of him hitting pads
that's incredible is it - yeah I don't
know tell him tell me what what video
but it's all good you know how we are
you can hit hard
you have good technique you tomorrow you
turn your hips and shoulders in the age
you do it right so that's very
impressive that it's only two years in
yo I'm learning I love it when people
take a chance - and you try something
new yeah that's all but you know we'll
get there so how many eight months had
you been in here like you say this is
old this was probably like a year yes a
year ago yeah still seriously though
good technique for someone who's been
doing it a year the way you're moving I
mean there's no fat to your movements
where I see what I'm saying like
everything you're doing it might not be
the fastest in the world of the most
devastating but you're doing it perfect
I think you're doing exactly how you're
supposed to do it and then you just get
better and better from there there you
go but we are talking about is the
change in your physique right you became
[ __ ] shredded right it's impressive
yeah thank you that's only through hard
work you can't do it any other way yeah
just just work it and and eating I was
all oh I'm sorry that's mine
it's hard to cut that off sorry about
that that's no worries man welcome to
the wonderful world of convenience there
we go
family yeah eatin like a [ __ ]
brah
yeah I'd like forced myself to eat to
gain weight to gain weight you know if I
can just move it around some but I
already have a quick metabolism so then
you add working out to that mmm so it's
like I'm burning so muscle setting
alarms to eat yeah yup
getting a little bit more rest too you
know they alarm see like how's that work
yeah like wake up and then you eat eat
go back to sleep
luxray what kind of father I do a lot of
like like ginger shots and like [ __ ]
like that to help like what
yeah to read all of that [ __ ] to cuz
like you said that she could [ __ ]
stomach up why who told you to get up in
the middle of the night and eat though
my trainer yeah yeah hmm yeah yeah I
would uh I would say that your sleep
cycle is more important than anything oh
well it's not like breaking my sleep
it's like more like yo eat oh you mean
like you said in a long while you're
awake yeah oh I see I've never heard
anybody telling someone to wake up in
the middle of the night need nah no I
did hear that that's why I was weird I
heard that from there was that movie
with Clint Eastwood where he played a
boxing trainer and his daughter that
famous actress played a boxer okay you
know that billion-dollar baby is when
that actress what is her name
Hilary Swank Hilary Swank the job when
Hilary think we could change on the ball
when she was training for that I think
that's what I read that they they had
alarm set which she would wake up and
mill the night and have a protein shake
oh really
and then go back to sleep again no I'm
not doing that okay no no no break-in to
sleep just regular eating habits just
reminding myself yeah I mean cuz I was
eating like twice a day
awesome just some rock star [ __ ] can't
live like that bro I said it's back do
you have a nutritionist or someone who
like handles your meals meal preps yeah
yeah cuz I don't cook right so it's like
they just deliver my
that's nice yeah it's really nice
actually yeah you know because I'm
single so it's like I don't really got
nobody in the house like cooking or
right making all that [ __ ] happen for me
so it just comes to this so you can make
sure everything's healthy exactly what
you want
all right up for you is fresh every
couple days that's a good thing to not
have to think about there yep the food
the food is like a big part of it and
working out is one thing people just
want to get big like you said I'm well
like we were talking about it's like my
embodying a soul right so the food is
further so mmm that keep that [ __ ]
meat alive yeah yeah keep the body
moving yep are you do you ever do yoga
or anything like that I would you would
yeah yeah I need a yoga instructor yeah
who's the best yoga issed
I don't know you do yoga yeah I love it
yeah yeah how long how long you oh yes
you do like some hot yoga yeah yeah yeah
yeah she's intense right it's kind of
intense yeah but it's it's great for you
mind touches you out loosens you up
that's what I need to do I need to
stretch you know yeah I do like regular
normal stretching but some yoga will be
I yeah it's good too because cuz the
heat in the room everything gets real
loose yeah you get really kind of dig
into like certain things stressed you're
free to test your flexibility and
stretch things a little bit more got you
just keeps you pliable got you you know
when you're doing a lot of hard things
like multi or wait like there's not not
enough stretching things out and totally
maintaining your range of motion
yeah especially as you get older how
often you do it I try to do it at least
once a week but I often fail but two
times a week in a good week okay yeah
it's alright but I mix it in but I can't
do one thing every day oh yeah bored
mm-hmm so in order to stay active I just
have to do a bunch of different things
that make sense it's whether it's
martial arts and running or lifting or
whatever it is I feel like through time
you like added those things in right
yeah it was just like all right I'm
gonna do this yeah the hill running is
the most recent thing okay cool
so what's Hale right English I take my
dog running through the steep ass
[ __ ]
and then you know sprinting up these
it's the most ruthless workout right you
know if you ever run hills yes yeah it's
the worst thing I do yeah I don't like
it sand dunes are the worst
that's probably sucks it sucks you never
get up there you see chief you keep
pushing and you're pushing sand and
pushing centers no hard you don't ever
bounce off anything right you're just
pushing through soft [ __ ] you try to
find like balance and yeah that's some
real martial arts [ __ ] though yeah for
sure
that's a mental [ __ ] exactly yeah you're
learning about yourself when you're
running up a [ __ ] sand dune you're
mastering a [ __ ] moving thing things
melting the whole time you're trying
yeah yeah okay and you're forcing your
body to do what your mind wants it to
Iceland [ __ ] I know you don't want to
do this yeah you're gonna do this that's
like I heard the Diaz brothers do some
crazy [ __ ] like swimming oh yeah they do
triathlons yeah look that Nick Diaz I
think it's now five times they swam back
from Alcatraz [ __ ] that yeah
Alcatraz and sharks barks that that's
what I'm with you that's so crazy
those guys are so crazy okay that's like
you and the sand dunes though well I
haven't do it I don't do sand dunes if I
had one near me I would do it I've run
hills which is definitely easier than
sand dunes but it's still hard as [ __ ]
mm-hmm good steep ass hill it's the best
for trinsic grass yeah dirt dirt rocks
just anything yeah just just rails damn
bro yeah I'm gonna get there someday
come on any place I'll take you out
we'll go running together I like to hike
it's a it's a great workout man and the
thing about it is it amps everything
else out yeah so like it makes your
kickin stronger there's more wind it
just accentuates your ability to explode
because you're running Hills right so
you're always going up it's like you're
doing these crazy plyometrics and then
you just develop this that's forward a
stronger power in your legs and your
lower trunk yeah yeah
more power yep that makes sense yeah I
feel like I will [ __ ] with it dude
love it because I like to just tune [ __ ]
out and just know yeah so like the pain
from running up the hill would just I
would be like yes yeah I'm not even
gonna think about this I'm thinking
about something else
yeah well and you get a goal right you
set a goal like a mile put yourself at
one mile whoo and then turn around and
go back for the other mile whoo yeah and
if you can if you can do that on good
steep-ass Hills when you're done you
feel like you fought a battle with your
brain whoo so you know you didn't want
to do that but you hit it uh all right
that's nothing compared to look some
people do yeah my dog that's that sounds
like you know some that we could unlock
later on in my life I think for
everybody doing something that's super
strenuous yeah all the time
is important yeah for sure for sure
that's that's part of the reason why I
[ __ ] with training you know so much
because it's not easy and it breaks you
yeah but you reach points where it's
like okay now I'm just cruising so I
need another challenge like you're just
sharpening the [ __ ] after a certain
point so it's like all right now I'm
gonna go run some sand dunes yeah swim
from Alcatraz so yeah I get it
there's dunes somewhere down there like
Orange County or they're free Facebook's
nothing to run a Manhattan Beach Park
yeah that makes sense
it's a park yeah yeah I was just there's
a video of Kevin Durant and Russell
Westbrook train in there I was about to
pull out yeah [ __ ] I want to see
somebody run on those tunes
Westbrook be doing it yeah all right
good
I know a lot of fighters do it in
Australia I believe Robert Whittaker
does it yeah see backwards when you doin
[ __ ] like this you on Sam that is
phenomenal in your body that's so hard
to do man I'm dying that's so hard to do
and I wonder if they're running with
just socks on it looks like they oh yeah
that's amazing that is difficult [ __ ]
man cuz that makes your feet strong
because you just you've using every
muscle in your toes to push through that
sand that's difficult [ __ ] there's
levels to this life yeah that guys
that's literally who's gonna go to the
top or who's gonna stop in the middle
yeah
yeah [ __ ] those little decisions you
make every day I just seen my whole life
just running up some juices there Mike
yeah that was cool
yeah yeah that's awesome it's like a
mental martial art - yeah yeah yeah yeah
Wow you're testing the mind hell yeah
and like getting stronger at the same
time yeah that's the cool part yeah so
it's like you could be up here the whole
time and you're building all of this and
becoming more explosive and more
dangerous yeah lighter on your feet and
just when you started training and
seeing these awesome benefits will you
like ah damn it why wasn't I doing this
all the time haha I'm actually happy
that out that I waited for a little bit
cuz I enjoy it it's not like old to me
you know what I mean it's not something
that I'm tired of that's a chore I'm
still figuring out new [ __ ] like all the
time and getting better you know what I
mean and like for me I feel like the
physical was probably like the first
thing to come to me as like as a reward
as benefit like I see the physical [ __ ]
but now I was like the feeling that I
get you know what I mean or like like we
said like posture and balance and
technique improving and [ __ ] like that
so it's like learning that and feeling
that and having that being a part of the
process I'm happy that now is happening
as opposed to being like old and played
out to me right yeah yeah that's
interesting
mm-hmm I think you'd love it either way
yeah I still love it I still love trying
ever ever ever yeah I'm 51 i ha started
training when I was really seriously
when I was 15 oh [ __ ] yeah damn suck
what the [ __ ] was that doing yeah will
you wrap it when you're 15 Wow when did
you first get in this - that's one thing
I really admire about a lot of rappers
guys are always working yeah rappers are
always in the studio
hopefully that's like a big thing you
know it's like there's a discipline
aspect to it though I don't think that
gets appreciated yeah yeah you have to
be you're always in the lab a always
working a constant
it's like training you gotta be you
gotta work at it it's competitive yeah
you're a better than you got to be in a
studio not work for producers you gotta
become a new [ __ ] knowing who's next
and who's been like working with them
and [ __ ] like that so like at the end of
the day yeah it's a crap [ __ ] I've been
in the studio since I was like 14 15 and
there was times where my dad used to
have to tell me like you'll get out of
the studio like go play with your
friends be a kid be normal like what I'm
saying like there was times that [ __ ]
happen and even now like I don't really
do normal [ __ ] you know and I mean I
might like go to the movies or like go
to Dave & Buster's or something like
that but like I don't do [ __ ] like I
just go to the studio much rather just
you know what I mean yeah create well
that's amazing that you figured it out
so young like yeah how old were you when
you knew you wanted to be a robber uh I
think I wasn't very great real [ __ ] I
think I was a third grade that's made it
to be a ninja turtle and I wanted to be
a rapper I think a rapper was like a
little bit more realistic I'm working on
being a ninja turtle now okay that's
amazing thing great it there great hold
you in third grade again do you nine you
know yeah yeah yeah that's when I
started writing my first rap sesh it
does hilarious yeah I was like watching
music videos and I remember seeing like
puffy and Biggie and Bunnell Thugs and
harmony is like one of my favorite
groups Wow I was like yo if I could do
that I'll be all right and then um by
the time I was like 13 that's when the
internet was really popular so you could
download like instrumentals and [ __ ]
like that so you didn't have to like
have Beats or anything
mmm then they started introducing you
know at-home equipment they have like a
little tascam four-track little [ __ ]
thing that you could hear me so I
started [ __ ] around on that mic doing
my own little home studio then
fruityloops came out started making
beats Cool Edit Pro was like the the
program back then before Pro Tools
and yeah that's how I got my start like
just in the [ __ ] in the in the create
just putting it together then I turn
like then about the time I was like 16 I
got like an internship at a UH at a
studio in Pittsburgh where I was
literally like answering the phones and
running errands going to pick up like
office supplies and [ __ ] like that
and then return they will pay me with
studio time so like I would just record
like off you know me off the clock you
know mean I had like four or five songs
and that turned into a record deal Wow
yep got my first deal at sixteen that's
an amazing story as well that's that's a
movie story mm-hmm
that's crazy you're always new yeah yeah
it was something that I worked out for
sure because it was like being him in
Pittsburgh you ever been a Pittsburgh
yeah you know it's pretty crazy out
there right crazy how like it's just a
really wild city like the Midwest so
it's like there's either a couple of
things you can do and there's not a lot
and working the job is like the last
thing that anybody wants to do in
Pittsburgh so all my cousins and
everybody that I know do different [ __ ]
than what I was willing to do I was like
you know I'm not trying to be that guy
like like that so it was like how am I
gonna make away from myself you know the
me how the [ __ ] am I going to get still
be fresh still you know me enjoy myself
have a good time but be safe and like
have fun it was music so it's amazing
you nailed it yes
and nailed it young yeah that's a
beautiful thing to know what you want to
do live and just be working towards it
have for many people that's the real
problem the real problem is like finding
a thing near you know find anything they
really love so much to me it all their
energy into yeah I mean I'm blessed to
grow up in a time to where technology
was like taking over and [ __ ] and I
think like if you're my age and you like
make music or got a camera or you know I
mean anything around that you good like
and now I think it's like if you have
anything to do a we'd like do not grow
it if you could sell it if you could
brand it
if you come up with light technology or
whatever it is like that's gonna be the
future for this generation it's like pot
there's gonna be a lot of that for sure
it's it's gonna open up to everybody I
think once they realize how much money
there really is in pot and how safe it
is in comparison the liquor and all
these other established things that
we've all no one has a problem with
alcohol companies right no no no nobody
has a problem with them nobody has a
problem what you drink in that twelve
[ __ ] afternoon like I get on planes
all the time people be like yo let me
get [ __ ] up on a plane fine we just
have to shift attitudes yeah yeah people
just have the wrong attitude about it
they did they think it's something
negative it's something that could be
negative to some people but that's like
everything else that's like food sex
gambling everything shopping everything
yeah shopping for sure people go crazy
people lose their mind shopping yeah you
can't buy enough things
yeah buying crazy [ __ ] just cuz just cuz
yeah that's that's as much of a
addiction than anything yeah but pot can
definitely for some people derail them I
don't think it's for everybody nah it's
a medicine so you gotta have a right
dosage that's that's a good way of
looking at and I think some people react
to it weird - yeah I mean certain
people's experiences aren't everybody
else's experience so it's like if you
got [ __ ] up on weed that's you know
it's like don't put that off on
everybody else and I think like like
anything it takes time to you know I
mean like I can't take percocet because
it's like that shit'll [ __ ] me up
because I don't do painkillers but I
think over a certain amount of time if I
had an injury my body would start to
react differently to a certain amount of
percocet but like off RIT it's gonna
[ __ ] me up
you know Janice I'm gonna throw up I'm
gonna do all types of [ __ ] but you know
after a while you know I mean there's
people who just pop that [ __ ] and just
walk around like you mean normally
that's a Malay with me smoking a joint
there's like there's sort of people who
could hit this and be in that corner for
the rest of the day me i'ma go do
everything that I have to do so it's a
medicine it's a dosage and you have to
train your
body for it I think that's true but I
also think some people might not react
to it correctly in terms of like
biologically yeah I think they might
have an allergy like it might be like
broccoli or something yeah there's
people out there that are allergic to
weird [ __ ] right there's some people I
think that just I've heard of that that
experience is not good for their like
they're allergic to it I mean you know
I'm just guessing I don't know I think
it's opinion like if you if you believe
it or not yeah I mean like if you want
to believe that I feel like you're
entitled to believe that and if you
don't want to believe that then it's
like okay cool you're that guy too
okay I don't know yeah because it's like
I'm on the fence because it's like you
know on one hand people I mean I don't
know [ __ ] yeah yeah whatever
it's medicine it's [ __ ] medicine yeah
and I like it there's a lot of people
that like it yeah it's not what
everybody thinks it is a wrong idea of
it me one of the things I found out real
early on is how many Jiu Jitsu guys
smoke weed and do Jiu Jitsu yeah in the
high-rollers state yeah yeah yeah yeah
high-rollers has these awesome events
where they do they smoke weed and then
they fight yeah in the jiu-jitsu match
yeah my partners are big part of that
Lonnie and Brees and they're the ones
who actually got me like kind of you
know into fitness so to see them like
and I'm the one who got him into weed so
hey to see if I cross over I never would
have known like you know I mean
jiu-jitsu dudes like smoke weed and like
we are about it like yeah there how's
that she helps you Jitsu it really does
another way it helps like slow it down
for you right I don't even know if it
slowed it down it's like it Tunes out
the rest of the world okay you become
freer it's very weird like more creative
there's it's definitely it's better for
rolling than it is for drilling guys
just like when someone's trying to teach
you something sometimes your brains just
not taking it in right so you just high
your brains not taking in but if you
were sparring it would be good watching
you just you flow better then yeah it's
what makes sense that makes sense I
haven't done jujitsu yet
let me get there eventually you would
love it and you got long limbs man you
mean perfect for choking people yeah
armbars triangles and [ __ ] let me get
there you could do it yeah I totally
fell for it
I feel like I'm gonna just [ __ ] with
stand up for like a couple years and
then just gradually do other things like
yeah I'm saying yeah I'll just probably
do jujitsu for like four or five years
yeah for sure you should just learn some
[ __ ] yeah it'll be great for you man
yeah yeah you're like I said you're
built for it that's the the perfect
frame for fighters is long who seems to
be if long as as long as you're strong
it's like the John Jones frame that's
the perfect frame right thank you
it's so you can't get close enough to
him he can hit you when he wants to and
then when he grabs ahold of you he's
strong enough to and he's better at
wrestling he's gonna throw you around
like if you could cut like that's the
perfect the perfect combination is long
and strong oh yeah
perfect yeah wait dudes like Sarafian
they buck that trend right tanks mm-hmm
but the best it seems to me like just
mechanically the best frame is the long
frame so you have like the best frame
for fighting Bucky ngratulations doesn't
guarantee success but it's a [ __ ]
awesome base there we go I'm start I'm
working with some Hey
yeah just like short dudes like me can't
put big guys in triangles I don't have
enough legroom there's not enough like
mechanically I'm sure you can figure it
out
not really give up on that one but long
guys can get triangles from all kinds of
places okay you'd love it super it's a
thinking man's game - mm-hmm you know
it's like you're playing a game yeah no
yeah thing that I like about it too is
that you can go full blast okay whereas
like if you're sparring you don't really
want to go full blast or hurt each other
right you want to be tempered measured
and just kind of touch each other but
when you do sparring in jiu-jitsu
because you're not striking each other
you're just wrestling and grappling you
guys go full blast okay it's amazing I'm
ready bro yeah I'm super with it like a
little bit that I've done I was I I cool
I could see right you know I mean yeah
yeah I'm down definitely got to go there
I just loved the fact that you're
interested in doing different things
yeah for sure I'm a learner do you do
read books do you do watch documentaries
i watch documentaries you know I have
read some books that I gravitate towards
what kind of documentaries you gravitate
towards like music
really all always about always about
music um let me see what else yeah it's
always about music like musician
searching for sugar man what was that
one that was about this dude who was a
guy who was making music but I want to
say it was in the 70s and he had a like
a little bit of buzz on his album and
then it died off for him and he went
back to work as a construction worker
mm-hmm but his music became insanely
huge in South Africa hmm he was a
superstar and there was all these
legends about him he was dead that he
you know there's just crazy stories
about who he was meanwhile this guy was
working as a construction worker damn
so in South Africa he's a [ __ ] mega
superstar like sells out arenas and a
spoiler alert it's a great documentary
to see it but he eventually goes to
South Africa and does this concert there
mm-hmm
you'll cry yeah you cry yeah you're like
oh my god you imagine this guy was
working as a laborer hmm and the whole
time was he was a superstar and he
didn't even know it day and then the
people see him they're singing along to
his music I mean the guy's bolon away I
would love that
it's a crazy documentary I check that
out it's it's insane to watch like how
could this be true yeah a damn it's
amazing I kind of feel like I heard the
name but I never never never no never
bro yeah it made me cry I gotta check
that off at the end of it you'll be like
wow oh hell yeah in this guy's
experience yeah right it's almost like
being released from jail or something
it's like exactly damn yeah
it's incredible holy [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna
check that out it's matin and see
how comfortable he gets on stage - Wow
there's amazing damn yeah his music is
good - man very very interesting is he
still alive I believe he is a lot as
fire he's alive right yeah so he's able
to see the proceeds from his movie and
his yeah yeah yeah but someone said I
think he gave away all his money really
I've read something but that might be
more of those rumors and and legends of
legend another myth damn Jamie find out
that dude gave his money away because I
felt like I read that I was like bro but
life to him is so surreal anyway truth
may be felt like he couldn't be a real
bona fide artist unless he gave away his
money or something crazy over cuz he
think I was living in like this that's
why I don't want to do that ayahuasca or
anything like that guy feel like that's
what's gonna happen to me you want to
give away your money like whoa no no
that's hilarious yeah it's too tricky
yeah you could you could get so you know
so so charity driven and just give away
everything mm-hmm
and then you're working for charities
mm-hmm just walking the earth barefoot
yeah he's on tour last year touring
theaters all over good [ __ ] Sugarman
yeah he's back hey smacking so did he
gave away all his money yeah Dave
Matthews covered one of the songs oh
yeah yeah damn he's doing good
so he ain't give away nothing beautiful
you might have but I don't the
documentary is really amazing it's one
of the best music documentaries I've
ever seen perfect thank you yeah it's a
good one tell me a good one my
documentary oh it's called behind the
cam yeah so Apple music oh okay hey did
that I just did that I just did that
beautiful man not I like to watch like I
watch this Pink Floyd documentary about
how they put together their albums and
[ __ ] like that um there's another one
about like
background singers who never like became
super popular but they're like part are
part of songs that you hear and that you
love and it's just like telling the
story like how writers and you know I
mean being a studio know what it's like
to live that life it's really cool
because I listen to harmonies a lot I
don't know if when you hear music I hear
like all the textures of it so it's like
I get interested in like what goes on
sometimes like in the background and
that was a cool story um [ __ ] what
was the last one that I actually was I
just watched
I'm watching this show actually you ever
heard Chernobyl
I've heard hardly shows amazing that
shit's kind of cool
yeah I heard it's great it's pretty
awesome but that's not music though what
is that on is that Netflix so HBO HBO
coming back Game of Thrones didn't kill
them
Chernobyl is it really yeah good I'll
shows it it's all you need Lena is a big
show HBO's back
Chernobyl what is it about the accident
yeah
mmm how many episodes is it I'm not sure
they're like streaming them now so
cyclone no it's dreams yeah yep oh this
one like the fourth or fifth episode I
think yeah all those networks that don't
stream everything yeah like they must be
it must suck yo to have like a show that
has to be on Thursday night and eight
losing out just today so weird people
want to watch things whenever they want
it right now five-part miniseries the
last episode is coming up this week
how do you think the movie theaters will
always be here mmm mmm [ __ ] no I want
that I think eventually ain't gonna be
gone what do you think I don't know just
it's what I kind of I like that they're
real you know that there's a place you
go they've already kind of came and gone
twice if you look around old Hollywood
there's old theaters that aren't
theaters anymore but there's new
theaters that have taken over them but
those buildings are still there for
whatever reason we still use a number
well people still like going to the
movies yeah it's like an it's a night
out thing yeah you know I just like it
cost so much that I keep screen and
actually put movies in there and
you got the popcorn it's like but it's
one of the few things that we do inst
with strangers is like be a part of an
audience it's like one thing the few
things we're and we do with giant groups
of strangers I think alike technology is
like removing that because people don't
like that I think people are
uncomfortable with it because most the
time we spend on devices
yeah for sure communicating through
devices and especially it were like
virtual reality becoming more popular
you know like people love access so it
was like if you're making them feel like
they're there like why would you want
random dude walking across your lap when
you can just be in the movie like yeah I
feel like they would just fit spend that
money on you know keeping you at home
like where you want to beat it's just my
opinion I don't know no I think you're
right and I agree with you 100% but I
also think as a community of human
beings it's nice to have things that we
all do together yeah it fosters like
kind of getting along better and
friendship I love that people that you
don't know nothing that's what's good
about sports I like concerts because the
concerts yeah yeah yeah
when you go to grow the whole group of
people see something mm-hmm like it's
nice you connect to tell yeah feels good
baseball games cuz yeah I've had fun at
games and not gave a [ __ ] about what was
going on but isn't the community that's
going on for sure one percent that's
what I mean I mean they never it's kind
of drinking and I'm fun that is an
important part of cities in those
communities that's one thing that I
think that it like a movie theater does
provide yeah I mean for sure concert for
sure and I'm not even mad that people
don't really go to the movies like that
now because it's like when you actually
do want to go you can go and it's not
full and it's not you know what I mean
like it'll be people there but it's not
overwhelming to the point where you got
like it [ __ ] up your movie experience
so it's like it's kind of you know it's
doable it's enjoyable it's it's
handleable yeah yeah it's cool it's fun
I like what movies is that right now I
am worried that people are eventually
going to all be living in some sort of a
VR world yeah I mean I feel like it's
design
and to move that way right you know what
I'm saying like you give people
something and they're gonna use it and
they're gonna get better yeah a new one
yeah yeah it wasn't have extra feature
yeah so it's like all right you know I
get it like [ __ ] have you [ __ ] with
any of that VR stuff yeah VR is awesome
do you ever do that there's a thing
outside of Disneyland where you there's
a VR game that you go through you go
through like this little like they have
a like a giant room and the rooms set up
for the what it was they called the void
yeah holy [ __ ] avoid VR and there's a
Star Wars one and there's a wreck-it
Ralph one okay and they're hilarious
I mean you're walking around you heat
from fire pick up a plastic gun you're
shooting at stormtroopers mm-hmm and you
shit's crazy it's crazy and while you're
doing it you like this is just step one
exactly this is gonna be a saying yeah
there's one here in those pieces yeah
bits and pieces like they already have
more you think that oh for show really
one or two percent I don't think that
really yeah why not because I think that
what they're showing you right now state
of the art they're selling it it's the
best again it's in competition it's
getting better and better all the time
but that's a good way to look at it
because they put it at myself I'm you
know no worries man yeah I just think
these people were very competitive yeah
the the the the money is in getting the
best [ __ ] out the quickest okay and
they're all competing with each other so
they're putting out like the bootleg
version and letting somebody smarter
test it work it and make the better
version and they'll come back and do
that later
well that definitely happens to I mean
that's what China does better than
anybody
yeah I take some [ __ ] and just redo it
I'd be feeling like this is just my
theory is like VR right it might be so
[ __ ] dangerous that they don't know
like how it was enough yeah exactly so
it's like they give us like little bits
and pieces of it it's it's like lettuce
you know they spoon feed it to us so you
don't kill us in the world just go crazy
and it's like you know what I mean like
yeah
because they probably tested it on
somebody and they died like
or you know what I mean for sure yeah
they look like oh [ __ ] we went too far
as I want let's like pull it back a
little bit and just give them that like
you said give them this version of it
you know what I mean but I feel like
there's more well I think when they when
you really don't know what the [ __ ] is
going on that's with military stuff I
think military stuff like weapons and
you know space ships and aircrafts that
they're developing mm-hmm
we don't know what the [ __ ] they're
doing they're doing some [ __ ] that we
have no idea right but I think with
things like consumer electronics like
technology I think what you see is what
you get I think this is as good as they
can do anything now they're working on
the newest best [ __ ] right you know and
that's coming around there was they're
always constantly in development we're
all competing against each other there's
no way they would hold anything back
really yeah I don't think so damn I feel
like there's a phone that charges into
second okay the way you have it out if
you're in or war right and your cellular
device goes down it's like you can't
plug it in and charge it it has to like
happen quick right right so like they
have that is in my opinion they just
don't give it to us but that all that
stuff the I could see your argument
because it's you're in a war they might
have better batteries like that the
military develop some new kind of
batteries and that's possible but
there's so much money in batteries mmm
like there's so much money if they had a
better way of doing it right if if
Samsung came out with a phone right
charged 100 percent in 30 seconds and it
eating Apple would have to do we'd have
to figure out how to compete with them
right they would have that out I
wouldn't hold on to that they no one
would hold on to that Kyle was just
dominating the powerful right it would
dominate the mark it is powerful but
that happens that's what it always
happens me that's how blockbusters out
of business right you know right right
right
that's why there's no more Tower Records
mm-hmm although jumping in our lifetime
yeah for show like 100% music isn't even
physical right like and I make music and
this doctor is not real right it's a
sound yeah it's a sound
and [ __ ] you know I don't know that is a
crazy way to look at music what is this
the r17 Pro which the company's latest
the fastest charging smartphone in the
world it advertises that 35 minutes is
all it takes to entirely fill up a dead
battery I was 7 months ago so mmm so
it's probably faster they got something
like that for sure
35 minutes so what do you think they can
do look for a full battery I would say
that there's probably a hundred cell
phones out there that can charge in five
minutes there's not a million right as
they can't source that much they may
charge more than this can well yeah I
would say like there's a military phone
that they might have a hundred of them
okay around the military but it's not
mass per day and it can charge up in
five minutes sure for sure for sure and
if this can do 35 minutes I mean to me
doesn't leap to me that [ __ ] is normal
this is energy that we're talking about
right right right bro like cars still
move off of gas like that shit's like
the Stone Age bro like shits going
electric you know what I'm saying like
that's not some spaceship [ __ ] so they
mean like at the end of the day like
they have this [ __ ] they just can't give
it to you because they they're killing
people testing it it's like it's like
food you know that I mean like they have
to approve this [ __ ] before it comes out
but they have a car that goes here it
just crashed into the wall you know what
I mean and somebody died in and they're
like well we can't put this on the
street yet it's like all that [ __ ]
energy yeah like what do you think they
have a car that's so fast they can't put
it on the street they had I just feel
like transportation in general you know
I mean communication transportation of
Technology the way we hear music the way
that we view things and [ __ ] like that
our whole experience tech technology
whatever the [ __ ] word we're being
spoon-fed FaceTime you know what I'm
saying it was like you used to have to
have the service to pet to FaceTime now
everybody can FaceTime you know what I
mean it's like people don't
call each other no more they just
FaceTime so we feel like oh man we came
up this is this was bah-bah-bah like we
feel good about that we feel excellent
about it but there's more
I feel like this just me I just feel
like they're just sitting on it you know
I mean oh wait and they give it to us
I don't think companies have any reason
to do that yeah the only reason to do
that would be to get rid of the stock of
the stuff authority selling that'd be
the only reason because sometimes when
companies announced a new products
coming people stopped buying the old
product like Corvette is having a
problem with that right now okay
because the Corvette let's call the zr1
right thing yeah it's a demon ridiculous
you can go to a store and buy a car that
has that much horsepower but a lot of
people don't want to buy them because
there's a new Corvette coming out in
like a year right that's a mid-engine
total read new design they don't want to
be stuck with the old one gotcha
people get weird yeah that's true so in
that sense they might be holding out on
what they're about to be able to do but
like we saw with that foldable phone
that Samsung tried to come out with
mm-hm and then they had to take it back
mm it's because it was so defective so
many of them were breaking right a giant
embarrassment and they pulled the whole
thing right and now they're trying to
rework it and figure out what to do with
it that that's like if a company has
something like that happened and that's
the number two smart phone company in
the were their number one right
Samsung's number one Huawei's number two
apples number three mm-hmm that's the
number one cell phone manufacturer in
the world and they got that kind of a
[ __ ] there's no way they're not
holding back anything I don't think so I
think they're trying to sell the best
[ __ ] they have right now and then
they're in development with the next
level [ __ ] right now but as far as like
what they can bring to market what they
have is what they bring the market and I
think like those on-screen fingerprint
sensors they didn't use to be able to do
that now they can you just touch the
glass and it reads it mm-hmm
all that [ __ ] is like they're just
trying to get it dialed in to the point
where they could sell it to enough
people and it doesn't break mm-hmm like
like that stupid folding did you see
that folding screen yeah it's like a
[ __ ] you could like it was a regular
phone but it folded though yeah yeah
yeah you know what fold opens like an
iPod iPad yeah yeah yeah that's stupid
but that thing kept breaking okay and
you know when it came out everybody's
like holy [ __ ] this is the future the
glass bed
I think there's like like you said
there's like the the people who just
freaked out about whatever is new right
right and then there's like [ __ ] that
really moves the you know I'm saying
like like really changes [ __ ] you're not
even sure and there's a huge difference
between those like you got the people
who just want the new [ __ ] and then you
got [ __ ] who's actually like
doing [ __ ] that changes things forever
like streaming changed music forever you
know and I'm saying so it's like mini
disks and all of that other stupid [ __ ]
that people were trying to do to change
music it didn't work you know what I
mean and it didn't exist so it's like
the one thing that stands out and
changes things forever that's what
people [ __ ] remember I don't
know if they're holding it or not it is
what it is but like there's some smart
[ __ ] who designed this [ __ ] for
us you know what I'm saying you know and
at the end of the day like that
you got people who just consume it and
they're just like oh man I'm here for
whatever whatever like you know what I
mean and then I feel like there's a lot
of people who understand it and know how
to play off of you know what I mean
those people's emotions and that's where
you get like you know I mean what we
have now and me personally I love
everything like I'm not a person who
like it's stuck with the old [ __ ] or has
to have all of the new [ __ ] either I'm
just like obsessed with life in general
like all of this [ __ ] [ __ ] me up but
it's crazy it's insane we live in insane
time we live in insane time it's cool
about today too is that we can go and
still like appreciate and use some of
the [ __ ] from the past like a record
player yeah use a record listen to some
old records right you know and then and
realize that wow this is how people used
to get their music sit in front of the
record player with headphones on I
remember being a kid doing them right
right would listen to albums they open
up the album looking at the art mm-hmm
that was a big part of an album right
was the photo lay out what was the the
pictures were it's crazy I write things
like the new [ __ ] ruins the older [ __ ] -
right it's like people still enjoy
everything yeah
you know it's just stages of it I love
that that old should exist yeah hell
yeah go back and listen to some of that
old stuff people don't watch tapes
anymore though UHF that's that's not the
move yeah those are dead and God vhses
never once someone would give you a copy
of a copy and it was all like it every
now and then I have lines through it and
[ __ ] you get like second third
generation copy friends yeah
VHS is our done bro you've every I don't
know if you remember this but you used
to be able to buy movies right after
they came out especially in New York
because dudes would sit in the back of
the movie theater like the little
bootleg join us yeah yeah yeah watch the
movie from like it was like a video
camera be like in their video and the
movie yeah yeah that was that was crazy
that was a crazy time getting more hide
and [ __ ] back then they were using all
of their technology as everything they
had that was everything they [ __ ] had
the crazy thing is that's not that long
ago terms of the human race that's not
that long ago
that's the 90s that's that's so this is
what 2019 is I was 20 years so you go
back 23 24 years maybe imagine if you
could see what the [ __ ] 24 years from
now is it's crazy I related to like when
I was younger in the 90s because I was
like a baby in the 90s I wasn't even a
teenager so 20 years from then was the
70s yeah and [ __ ] was totally I'm saying
so it's like now from 20 years from for
that to be the same timeframe like that
[ __ ] is crazy to me you really wanna
know how crazy it is man get yourself
into like a 1970 Plymouth mm-hmm and
drive that thing and realize that in
1970 that's how people drove they drive
this thing they like it barely knows
where where you're sorry yeah hell yeah
I do this with the steering wheel
I didn't even power steering and in the
60s and [ __ ] bro like yeah a lot of them
didn't yeah a lot of them didn't but do
you those cars were terrible
and that was just a few years ago I mean
in terms of like human history right
if you
in a block of time in history like if
you look at the difference between 1820
and 1840 in our head it's like that's
the same [ __ ] mm-hmm 1820 1840 what the
[ __ ] was different there was nothing
different yeah but if you look at our
generation yeah 40 years ago to now it's
insane true
that's it since it doesn't make sense
it's nuts it's a bear we're barely the
same thing bro it's crazy it's crazy
have you driven the Tesla no I have it
very good the preposterous it's a
preposterous car what's the deal with
them there that's so fast it doesn't
make sense really every other car you
drive afterwards will feel stupid you
could drive mine yeah yeah you drive it
their dad legit it's the most ridiculous
thing I've ever driven in my life [ __ ]
it doesn't make any noise it doesn't
make it makes zero noise it's a [ __ ]
rap music video entourage style girls in
their underwear house dancing bottle the
champagne a girl in my house just follow
you to the camera just to see who rings
your doorbell what were we just talking
about Teslas oh yeah yeah it's a
spaceship it's next level if you think
that they're holding back anything in
the automotive world drive that thing
that's C nah that's that's the thing I
feel like all cars are gonna look alike
and they're gonna look like Tesla's mmm
so you're gonna have this superfast
woman for like the elite [ __ ]
but they're gonna have like regular ones
and then we're all gonna have the same
car we're all gonna have the same fun
we're all gonna have the same watch and
well because it controls everything like
you're they control your house so it's
like everything is integrated the TV the
Xbox that's like you all want it in one
so the only way to do that is for
everything to be the same so like if the
Tesla is that ill I never drove driven
one but if it's that ill I don't see why
people wouldn't be into it like it's
just the pain the acids it takes a long
time to charge okay is it I mean even if
you have a test little supercharger
thing like I
one a wall-mounted charger that's it's
like more answers height it's nice but
it still takes a few hours to charge if
it's almost dead okay well where as you
can get gas in like five minutes exactly
don't they have like portable chargers
no no no you needing same amount of
power tell Howard that thing but how
long giant batteries in it it takes
hours and hours to fill up that doesn't
sound like fluid well because it goes
317 miles you see this race they did
with the tunnel is that two Tesla's at
the same spot like I guess it's in
Hawthorne where they have it the one on
the right is using the tunnel they have
use leader than the one who left is
going above ground now is this tunnel
like auto-drive yet so I [ __ ] I think I
kept those tracks on the side so that it
could stay oh look how fast at 127 miles
an hour I'm so not comfortable with that
and it slows right down the way that it
moves differently that's how robots are
gonna kill us that's crazy it's so fast
you can't believe how fast it is that's
it that guy's not moving at the top and
the guys moving very fast take some four
and a half minutes to go the same time
it takes this guy of minute I hope that
guy's battery's dead as [ __ ] on the
right I'll tell you that if you stomp on
that thing for that long you better be
prepared for that [ __ ] to drain quick
especially when it's in ludicrous mode
that's what they call it ludicrous mode
yeah and now they have Ludacris plus I
don't even want to turn that [ __ ] on I
don't need that what kind of [ __ ]
unhappy with ludicrous mode doesn't ask
before don't you think there's some car
company trying to beat them
yeah well be right Tesla has a roadster
have you seen the Tesla Roadster oh my
god Jaime pull that up it's a spaceship
it's just little sports car looking
spaceship that goes 0 to 60 in 1.9
seconds it's a spaceship it's a
spaceship that's the Tesla Roadster yes
I like that it's a dope looking little
car the roof comes off - that's real oh
my god that thing's a demon what I think
is a Dean how much does that cause I
think it's $200,000 it's real yeah it's
not out yet I'm working on it
oh ok they're working on releasing it
soon yeah 200 grand
look at that 1.9 second zero to 60 yeah
I don't need
they just seen the electric cars it
seemed like the future but again that
one's gonna be interesting cuz it has
six hundred miles it you know six
hundred and sixty miles I think without
without charging which is long-distance
minds like 317 ok the ones they have
they are like three seventeen that's
dope yeah that's amazing
it's wild like my mind is literally
blown by the [ __ ] yeah make mine too
like for real like that [ __ ] blows
imagine imagine if you're one of those
people that makes those things yeah like
that's your job I feel like it's like
really a process like scientific like
you know cuz you don't want to buy you
to hurt themselves something you know
what I mean so you have to get it just
right
sure I was like what's the process of
that like what are the [ __ ] are they
doing like with technology in in
electricity in a car yeah and they have
all these safety features they've Auto
Drive that's the thing so it's gonna be
so fast gotta have a hella safety Jesus
Christ I can't turn this thing off oh
there it is the same girl I don't know
she's persistent she's a go-getter I
don't know she gonna go get some knows
but yeah man I mean it's when you drive
something like that and you realize like
oh okay just 30 40 years ago cars are
these stinky weird things that barely
steered right and now you have these
things that it seem like they seem like
they're from a futuristic movie mm-hmm
and you can get them right now it's
crazy uh like it's insane
because people like okay what are we
gonna be without transportation we got
to go somewhere right we got to get
there somehow
what is this Jamie I was looking up I
thought I saw something today about a
Lamborghini electric car but this fell
into this hole of the terzo Milenio some
new it is electric car by Lamborghini
that self heals it has some sort of
carbon fiber technology that allows it
to fix itself if it cracks while it's
dry I don't know oh yes we text cracks
and damages we go
it's a [ __ ] transformer there we go
it's a transformer it's gonna heal
itself out
when you'd heard of it no self-healing
oh my god there we go
he's gonna fix itself sorry to distract
from that but yeah but it's Italian
right yeah listen to me that's my people
it ain't gonna work
those savages it looks the same though
this they're thinking big if you want to
go on a long trip in a Lamborghini
you're out of your [ __ ] mind that
thing will leave you in the middle of
the desert they think and be that's it
yeah that is a tease weird unbelievably
good-looking car like tires are god damn
that looks like the future that's fire
look at that thing so spaceship but you
if you take one of those you know that
it's made by Italians right you know
[Applause]
it's the accent with the car it makes it
it's so flamboyant look at the wheels on
that thing what the [ __ ] is with those
wheels wow that's crazy
an Italian spaceship yeah yeah cars are
getting closer and closer to spaceships
yeah what if people start flying around
you comfortable with that I'm not want
anybody landing on my house landing on
the house air Accidents yeah man those
don't seem too good no in the regulation
of what Lane you staying yeah we worked
so hard to develop these roads like
we're huh where are we going now like
what's going on here do you imagine if
we had like a floating bubble highway
system right like there's a these
balloons held on by by rope that go all
the way to the ground and that marks the
pass where you're allowed to fly your
own car through huh but people don't
look and they slam into each other or
not man you're out there in the park
with your heads regulation would suck on
that yeah man how do you stop people
from they would have to be autonomous it
would have to be like Tesla Auto drive
so it just takes you up and it just
brings you around mmm would have to be
something like that that makes sense
yeah we couldn't leave it up to people
not with flying hell no it's too many
different personalities yeah but then
it's gonna be lazy people that don't
charge they're [ __ ] flying car and
then it gets up there and it's like that
did that that that that like you didn't
charge it you shouldn't be able to take
off if it's not at a certain
but if it's if it's capable of dying I
agree ground it then when you're gonna
need more regulation so we have more
government ha ha air laws have to that's
the only way may we need more government
more regulations air cops oh my gosh the
air police let's not talk about those
air police they'll be even more on edge
the ground in the ground police oh yeah
yeah cuz they're there in the air yeah
yeah they're probably gonna be super
paranoid up there or sure for sure
well if we ever do eventually get to
space travel if human beings ever do
figure out how to like go to other
planets to set up a civilization on Mars
or something that's probably what the
real next level future of humanity is
gonna be push other than artificial life
if we can really figure out how to set
up a base somewhere mm-hmm do you think
you would ever go if there was a base on
Mars it takes six months to go to Mars
if there was a threat on Earth a threat
yeah it was like you know earth is about
to be [ __ ] up like an asteroid yeah I
would you know I would if if Mars was
alright I would try to go I would take
my family and go yep totally Wow
to save my family that makes sense to
save your family yeah whatever yeah what
if Mars was awesome what if they figured
it out if it was awesome yeah I rather
just die on earth yeah I'm cool here oh
yeah I'm good yeah I just wonder once
they actually do start going from Earth
to other planets how many people are
gonna be willing to do that rich folks
you think so
I think rich folks want to go into orbit
I don't think they want to go to Mars I
don't think there's a way to live there
just mate maybe if you can come back
let's say we're far in the future
vacation yeah take a little vacation to
Mars it takes money to get there
everybody you think if it takes six
months to get there hold on that's
another one so long I think I think a
lot of people would do that I think a
lot of people would do it I think you're
right if they knew they could come back
because then they'd be able to brag
about it
mm-hmm people would love to brag about
going to Mars it's like that time-travel
thing we're like take six earth months
get their butt over you it's like two
weeks oh I don't think it works that way
but yeah I was wondering how doesn't
have to be like at the speed of light
yeah yeah now again Dee interesting you
might be able to go save some time if
you do do that you could lose some time
though I know that's a fact like if you
go into space at a particularly high
rate of speed and then you figured out
how to come back like your brother your
twin brother would be way older than you
mmm yeah damn yeah that makes sense I
want to see this Brian Cox show do you
know Brian Cox's the astrophysicist he
had a show he did in LA and in the back
they have this gigantic screen and it's
this real high-resolution screen and it
showed all of the galaxies in the
universe it showed all them that you
know just all jammed in together with
like appropriate space in between them
and you look at it and you just go what
what the [ __ ] is that we're in that
thing we're one dot in just trillions of
dots of all these other galaxies data
through the known universe I've never
seen anybody show it that way mm-hmm and
one of the things he talked about was
that the rate of time is not the same
for each person even on earth like
depending on where you go and what you
do what speed you travel at if you and I
were born on the exact same day and we
both got a watch and that watch was
perfectly calibrated and you put your
watch on and I put on my watch on then
we met when we're 80 if our watches are
still working the time would be
different mm-hmm because we've lived
through different time and it might be
only increment like a tiny increment
like a second or a couple seconds but
enough so that in the the whole unit a
no sighs [ __ ] so while I'm there
watching this thing the whole thing just
blew me away I was like this is a crazy
way to look at the universe this is it
right here ah yeah if anybody gets a
chance to view that's just one galaxy
that they're showing those it's a one
galaxy colliding with another galaxy
it's [ __ ] spectacular whoa yeah
[Laughter]
do you get in the space documentaries
about to you got to I just don't believe
everything that everybody tells me so
what about [ __ ] like that so I would
have to get it from a reliable sports
source you would have to tell me like
the good okay
space [ __ ] any Neil deGrasse Tyson ones
Lawrence Krauss has got some good stuff
he's got good audiobooks to that Brian
Cox guys as good as it guys he's a
genius
he used to be a musician okay he's
actually in like a pop band okay I think
in the 80s in the 80s yeah like a
popular pop band and he's a legit
astrophysicist he just talks about space
yeah he gives these very entertained
with this guy Robin ins and they have
this like stage show mm-hmm and you know
he comes out and talks about things and
explains things but explained when he
explained that time thing to me that if
we live the same life that our watches
would be different yeah that's crazy
I love [ __ ] like that I'm writing his
name down Brian Cox CEO X not like the
dicks yeah I wouldn't put that name in
there course that could be a problem
yeah if you get a chance to see that
show man it's it's a it's a good thing
to see too because it's so different
than anything else you go to see like
for me I'm always at comedy clubs
I'm always hidden you know either in the
audience or on stage so to be there at
this place in the audience of this weird
kind of like show slash science seminar
and it's amazing now it's time yeah that
[ __ ] seems crazy as [ __ ] to learn it
laughs yeah I gotta I gotta get you on
some science documentary oh yeah when
you're smoking weed and watch the
science documentaries that'll help my
music listen the real thoughts come out
kids we realize there's no getting away
if you if you you know that paranoid
feeling that you get sometimes you get
too high if you have that paranoid
feeling combined with a science
documentary on space hmm then you
realize yeah we're we're all very
insignificant exactly and you seem extra
high because you're high watching space
yeah it's like you others do too stars
how have you gotten high your whole life
I started when I was 16 when you were 16
mm-hmm
I started smoking every day wow they're
so right around the time where you were
becoming successful as a rapper mm-hmm
it was really like high school because I
hated school
and I was just so done with it and I was
selling pot and my mom found out and she
was lowkey just super cool with it was
like like I smoke you smoke we smoke and
you mean wow it actually helped me get
through school like to make it made it
tolerable right sure I was able to deal
with like the [ __ ] that I didn't want to
deal with because I'm an intelligent kid
I just really didn't like school I
didn't like the school that I went to
was good I went to a nice school but it
was just I grew up in a time where it
was like mmm saying was we're so well
every school for every kid is not what
you want to do every day it was just not
what you want to do every day and like
you got teachers who say certain things
to you and it's like all right I
understand what I'm really here for you
know I mean and I see Who I am to you
and you let it be known it's kind of
hard to like take those people serious
and want to do the work and all Russians
want to follow their lead
yeah that's like for me that was the
bare minimum was like graduate high
schools like I could move on with the
rest of my [ __ ] life after that
yeah we'd help me get through high
school hey everybody help me I believe
you yeah it makes sense yeah there's a
lot of [ __ ] that's not that fun but when
you're high becomes interesting a lot of
[ __ ] yeah yeah it's why air travel air
travel is always better when you're high
way better way better and you could take
THC pills you gotta bulls you do
whatever you will come like appreciative
of the experience exactly yeah yeah yeah
just be up there flying for real yeah uh
there's something to me about music
listening to music - in a plane while
you're high hmm she said it has like
extra impact putting headphones on a
plane surrounded by all these people no
one's talking flying through the sky
going 500 miles an hour and 30,000 feet
above the rocks
and that music kicks in hmm yeah yeah
something about old music - for me like
like lately I've been getting into a lot
of like really old rock and roll mm-hmm
you know just lit just imagining what it
would be like to like to be around those
being alone you know see Keith Richards
and Mick Jagger in the 70s or you know
see Little Richard mmm to see James
Brown's live hell yeah James Brown
perform a lot mm-hmm yeah yeah
there was nothing it's hard for us to
imagine there was nothing like that
before them mmm you know mm-hmm like
there's there's levels of like impact
that those early musicians have that
it's hard to really historically put
into place because there wasn't anybody
like them before that nope no
rock-and-roll stars no rap stars mm-hmm
think of how reason that is yeah super
new stand-up comedy is only about maybe
like 70 years old [ __ ] like that maybe
maybe really maybe you could say a
hundred if you want to get crazy hmm
but rappers like 30 30 years old 40
maybe maybe Ford yeah yeah and it keeps
evolving names of origin yeah like music
in general
my favorite genre is like pop music
like I love anything that could be
considered pop because it changes with
the times but you have these mega stars
you know what I mean who just transcend
like like it's like soul they're beat
there's larger than life like Michael
Jackson you know I'm saying like he's
bigger than just music you know I mean
like and you you become a legend like as
time goes on but like to be a living
legend like living in those times and to
be around those people that are really
hear their music and experience them in
[ __ ] like that I feel like that [ __ ] is
crazy and it's like it's a gift like for
the fans it's a gift to be that person
it's a responsibility as well but just
like
to be the one like like Beyonce you know
I mean yeah like that [ __ ] is crazy to
me like to be the one yeah yeah Michael
Jackson was the one when there was no
one before mm-hmm there was no real one
like him I mean there was Elvis and
that's about it right it was other ones
that were big it was very popular very
famous but Michael Jackson transit he
transcended so hard I was listening to
WB CN radio in Boston as a rock and roll
station and they were like I know as a
rock roll station but this song is so
[ __ ] good we're gonna play it anyway
yeah and they played Michael Jackson
yeah and we're like wow he'd been
performing as a kid so he worked his
whole life to get yeah to be what it
would look like 30 or something like
that one yeah probably when he was on
his PGA
there was no there's no roadmap for him
ah
that [ __ ] is amazing amazing and he did
you know funk music and he went to disco
wow yeah yeah man and I would have loved
of seeing him live before the
controversy right you know just to just
experience him as an artist yeah without
having anything attached to it yeah what
he did or didn't do I don't know what he
did right you know have no idea right
doesn't look good right but I would have
loved have seen him without the burden
of that filming it must have been insane
and only just to just to see like he was
like a like weird saying it needs to be
a different word for work
mm-hm you know because sometimes does
not work right passion price just it's
way better than work mm-hmm
he's a different you should have a
different word for a star yep because he
was like a supernova yeah he was some
rare thing yeah yeah yeah that might
happen once every hundred years yeah
yeah yeah there's legends like Elton
John watts do right didn't [ __ ]
there's lay all kinds of legends well
then there was Michael Jackson right he
was above all of them yep it was a mania
yeah kids would dress like him everybody
wanted to wear those thriller jacket
right right yeah there's an art to it I
feel like every musician has a choice
like if they want to go there with it
right yeah I feel like L like the Elton
John's and like even like prints and
[ __ ] like that they stay true to
exactly who they were not that Michael
Jackson didn't stay true to who he was
but he put himself into he put himself
out there for the world he did
everything he dad car toons mm-hmm PS
sneakers he had he did everything you
know out of the Beatles music yeah he
bought yeah like you know I mean [ __ ]
dude on other people's music yeah but I
yeah hell yeah he was doing the hell of
[ __ ] yeah I just think there was no
roadmap for the poor guy right you know
yep when you're living in that fantasy
world that nobody else can understand
right right and there's no one before
you and then everywhere you go people
screaming mmm-hmm he never had a break
done
there's no breaks there's no you can't
do it he couldn't do anything no no no
not normal
nothing that's crazy that was so the I
wonder if that what that would be like
into like if Michael Jackson came around
today I mean didn't exist before he
would for sure be a huge star but I
wonder if it would be as crazy because
there's so many more stars now than
there were back then
mmm-hmm because of the internet because
just more venues and outlets for
musicians for me for basically everyone
for comedians for everyone right there's
more outlets yeah so because it's more
outlets there's more famous speech right
I wonder if he would be as correct it
would be as insane because back when he
was that famous it wasn't like anyone
that was parallel not even close
mm-hmm no man what do you do listen to
old stuff yeah listen to I like we I'll
do like 90s R&B now I like funk music I
like like Bootsy Collins alright I love
Jimi Hendrix he's one of my favorites
I like Curtis Mayfield Marvin Gaye
freaking cool in the game [ __ ] I
listen to everything bro I like a lot of
the older soul music like The Spinners
Patti LaBelle you know I'm sampling I
was raised on
everything my dad listen to Bob Marley
he listen to freakin oh we listen to a
lot of sting in the police really yeah I
love staying he's one of my favorites
just the auto jams you know what I'm
saying like the classic [ __ ] like you
could put on any song like for real for
real and I [ __ ] with it because I listen
to a lot of different music and yeah oh
yeah Marvin Gaye man yeah he's one of my
favorite he was phenomenal
yeah and Marvin Gaye was really good and
this is tragic story that was crazy
his dad shot him it's so crazy I I dated
a girl once this girl was so nuts mmm
and I we were talking about shot okay no
no we were talking about Marvin Gaye you
know saying that's like it's so insane
that his dad shot him and she said
imagine what a piece of [ __ ] he had to
be for his dad to shoot him Yeah right
and I was like what I go no no no no no
no no why would you assume he's the bees
each it was dad [ __ ] shot if he's a
piece of [ __ ] why does his dad just get
away from that's shooting him his dad's
a piece of [ __ ]
like but it was amazing she was like
instantly thinking he's a piece of [ __ ]
yeah like I'm like I don't get your
logic it's really she's someone who grew
up with a good she's still loved her
down uh-huh she was close with her dad
yeah so I was like that what I don't
know my dad so doesn't to me I'm like
that dad shot him because he was Marvin
Gaye and he's probably upset that his
son had become Marvin Gaye truth imagine
being Marvin Gaye - we all your songs
are like the best music - [ __ ] - yeah
and he didn't have there was nothing
there was no slide into the dm's now
they had to find him physically yeah but
he seemed like kind of like a faithful
guy like you seemed like he would find
like one shake yeah just [ __ ] her right
album about it that would be a good
narrative mm-hmm I think it's hard for
those dudes if they're singing about
[ __ ] all the time it's coming their
way
they usually like just wanna [ __ ] one
girl like that right those those love
songs yeah exactly when the music's dark
like easy either
you mean they he's [ __ ] mad [ __ ] he
wasn't like this one
he was known as Marvin Gaye that was all
I remember he said sexual healing I mean
when you get that feeling he needs
sexual healing but the [ __ ] made him
feel better yeah when he was with her
that's a big difference between the
NWA's first album sexually there's some
[ __ ] from like the early gangster rap
days you listen to today like woah yeah
yeah like this is this is crazy stuff
mmm I remember it at the time when it
was first coming out mm-hmm and no one
knew what like no one could understand
there was no music like this before and
then all sudden you have iced tea yeah
that was before date what the freaking
parental advisory on there they made
that because like there's like your
parents make sure y'all check this out
before your kids get it it was Al Gore's
wife it was tipper gore mm-hmm it was
she was the one who was in charge it was
like she was leading the charge yeah
against I think it was her make sure I'm
right about that is it I'm not mad at
that that may wrap music better you
think so oh yeah it's like made it more
dangerous I'll be put to the extreme yes
these shoes they were trying to irate at
our movie they're trying to ban some
stuff though they were trying to ban
some using like oh well that was Florida
or it is crazy don't [ __ ] around in
Florida they catch you in Florida
yeah they arrest people for anything you
can get it rested for obscenity in for
I'm straight I'm good not going in
Florida Florida was a go but I'm not
going crazy in Florida yeah Braddock
County yeah yeah just don't get arrested
for swearing yeah that's what they got
to Live Crew for explicit lyrics yeah
[ __ ] I'm good or no forget about that
right yeah like those guys would like
the Lenny Bruce of rap right like Lenny
Bruce's a guy want to get arrested a
bunch of times for stand-up comedy he
wouldn't change his words and his you
know swearing on stage for the court
that was 2 Live Crew never going to jail
for like for rap yeah that's crazy
it's crazy for saying some for saying
something somebody doesn't like it so
they want to put you in a cage Wow cuz
they don't like how you're saying wow
they don't like what you're saying they
don't like how you're saying it like
could you arrest someone if they just
that's somewhere what if there in the
comfort of their own house mm-hmm and
they said the things that are in that
mm-hmm
is that illegal yeah could you yell it
out the window yeah could I Drive down
the road yelling it out the window right
should be able to it should be able to
[ __ ] are you to tell people they can't
do that
but then Florida they're like nope
obscenity rap Florida's like its own
world don't like that's why when [ __ ]
goes down it's like alright and in this
Florida yeah yeah yeah it's it is it's
so its own world know that it's being
overrun with invasive species mm-hmm a
lady got attacked by a car alligator
just yesterday do you hear what that
Jamie I feel like that happens all the
time down there happens all the time
more often than not yeah more often
rather than not nope nothing the good
way said more often now than before
because there's a lot of them yeah I
could imagine being a gator not having
nowhere to go sneaking in a Florida want
to eat some stupid lady yeah look who
this is I'm a slow [ __ ] and I've been
around for a long ass [ __ ] time yeah
hungry as [ __ ] yeah Florida is [ __ ]
crazy
was eat and you just look at that lady
like she's so annoying
yeah maybe no one will even notice I
don't even eat ladies but I'm gonna do
it today
those are they dogs they love these
people's dogs that's what's [ __ ]
forget snack viewing if you're now yeah
I love dogs though so I don't know but
if I was a gator a dog would be a good
snack I was a good meal per for
preferred dog dinner lady yeah people
have clothes on that adjust their
sneakers and [ __ ] man that's annoying
yeah yeah shoes yeah it's good if you
didn't live in California what state
would you live hmm
mm if I didn't live in Cali what state
what I live in not Georgia not Florida
not Pennsylvania not New York not New
York huh no too crazy
might be upstate New York uh me maybe
upstate you gotta go you gotta worry
about ticks - yeah [ __ ] takes [ __ ] ticks
and then everybody gets Lyme disease out
there
yeah damn I don't I don't know I never
thought about that but the [ __ ] hits the
fan I love California tsunami rolls over
us maybe I'll go to Australia every time
I'm on the highway nowadays and it's
jammed up bumper-to-bumper I just say
imagine something happened mmm this is
just Thursday there's no regular
Thursday and it's bumper-to-bumper yeah
imagine if some [ __ ] went to have you
[ __ ] up you wouldn't know what to do
when it rains out here people don't know
they panic they slam into each other
drive it's like dog it's just rain it's
just water coming out the sky oh Jesus
Christ it's a strange place to live
right because people aren't tested out
here by climate yeah yeah on the East
Coast they're tested by climate yeah
yeah that winter comes that's snowy wind
comes you gotta [ __ ] ride
you got to winterize your car yeah got
to get snow tires don't know about that
350 tornadoes last week where ya heard
about in the Midwest where every tornado
alley [ __ ]
yeah they got framed up yeah I was like
Ohio and where else Kentucky I think it
bunched handing out roses here he got
hit hard yeah man I mean I don't know if
that's really because of climate change
those are ramping up but if they've
ramped up in unprecedented levels like
that and it becomes impossible to live
in Ohio or Kentucky or anywhere with
this tornadoes you imagine I'm nuts that
is if we find out that the center of the
country
it's just tornado like a tornado bowling
area Wow bowl filled with tornadoes
Florida you're just dodging hurricanes
most of the year
basically lucky if happened where you
are yeah you get lucky yeah you're a
dick sticking out into the ocean and
right where all the tornadoes deformed
or all the Hurricanes conform they it's
like warmer waters right here we go
we'll get started right here yeah [ __ ]
hurricanes I've been in a little baby
hurricane before and I was living in
Boston which is pretty far away from the
ocean in terms of where my house was and
it's still it was like wow
yeah and I was a little baby one it was
nothing by the time it got to us it was
nothing I lived in Japan for two years
and there's gonna have some crazy
[ __ ] earthquakes over there oh really
why you were there yeah they had
earthquakes and typhoons you saw both
yeah [ __ ] yeah oh yeah wait
was an earthquake bug bad you've never
been in one here yeah I've got a baby
one I look like a 5.5 bro like I'm
talking about whole room just shaking
like it's like a ride or a universal
light because you see [ __ ] moving it's
like damn is this really happening and
this [ __ ] happens bro like the
earthquakes over there are insane wow
man you know and they get some crazy
rain like when the typhoons come that
[ __ ] gets really violent yeah yeah yeah
the Japanese are you know they they hold
it down and said what were you doing
living over there
my parents are military my mom was in
there for a little bit but then she got
out and my dad was in there he got out
but remarried so that's how I stayed in
the military thing was my stepmom and I
would move we would live on base you
know I mean for like two years or
whatever and then I would move back with
my mom Wow
what was it like living in Japan it was
crazy like it was fun I lived in the
late 90s so it was like when technology
was first changing mic music was just
now going into mp3s and [ __ ] like that
so there was that Pokemon was really
popular over there yeah it was fun like
just being a kid like running around
[ __ ] it up in Japan it was cool man
that's funny as hell that's a and an
interesting little extra level to your
brain right yeah you grew up those two
years in a completely different kind of
culture yeah so have a different
understanding of what's possible right a
lot of percent I think that's so big for
show them [ __ ] yeah yeah how about a lot
for sure it was cool it has to right as
far as your perspective uh-huh it's
being around well I've only been a Tokyo
for a few days only once when I was like
this is one of the trickiest place I've
ever been in my life phrase so
interesting it was crazy living there
was wild like no TV like regular TV they
don't got any like American TV stations
so for two years I was just like haha
disconnected yeah like I didn't have
[ __ ] yeah and this is so this is before
Netflix and everything to write more
YouTube mmm Wow yeah that's amazing yeah
it was probably really good for you
nice sucked I couldn't watch wrestling
but it was really good for your brain no
no I need it I need my entertainment
[ __ ] that I need to be a part of the
world
hahaha I couldn't buy all the CDs and
[ __ ] that everybody was listening to it
was it was wack did you learn to speak
Japanese this a little bit yeah yeah Wow
baby Japanese just to get around a [ __ ]
but I forgot it though you forgot it all
it not all of it well it'll come back if
I like yeah I mean you run me through it
but I can't sit here and say no Japanese
words how hard was it to learn it wasn't
difficult no no no it's not difficult
reading it is difficult oh yeah a friend
because they have symbols or characters
so it's like one character means like
three of our words um Wow yeah yeah and
then they have like three different
styles of writing it too so it's like we
have print and cursive they don't know
re different ones oh that sounds so
annoying yeah it's weird
on one hand you don't want it to go away
because it's an ancient language but
another hand you like you clean this up
simplify this ship I honestly think they
got it down pat you know they said LD
want us to have a [ __ ] know that [ __ ]
you know I'm saying like at the end of
the day that I
we'll learn English if we want to but if
you want to learn Japanese it's gonna be
difficult bro I want to learn some Asian
language because I buy reading like
Twitter messages mmm from you know how
much the many more characters they had
yeah they can write books yeah 140
characters like how many words is that
though yeah you know that's a lot of
[ __ ] words if it's 280 so I mean 280
are those Asian with this Chinese or
Japanese those little symbols it's a lot
of talking man yeah and it's hard to put
like the ingredients on [ __ ] oh yeah
do they have symbols for numbers or just
use numbers I forgot what the numbers
look like I think it symbols really yeah
yeah like not imagine that is like 1 2 &
3
oh wow right yeah you know I never even
thought of that
yeah what does what is uh let's go with
Japanese does Japanese does the japanese
language have symbols that record
numbers like you would write the letter
the letters th r ee 4 3 like that like
you would write 3 or you'd be the number
3 mm-hmm do they have that in Japanese
not cuz Japanese like each each knee son
she there's different different whole
different words for it so it's like one
is Ichi
so this symbol where have you spelled
that in Japanese I'm starting to kinda
remember what it looks like now do you
think if you could move back there right
now you just get right back and explain
things after a while sure David Lee Roth
moved there van Halen the lead singer
yeah he moved down there and took kendo
lessons mmm he lived there for like more
than a year I would probably appreciate
it more now as an adult do you think so
yeah yeah cuz that's the kid you kind of
just want to run wild and do everything
that's right on TV but oh he must be an
annoyed you were stuck there it was kind
of weird you know what I mean I was 13
like when I go crazy it was fun for a
little while but yeah you want to go
back home
you mean of course but as an adult I
feel like I would I would benefit a lot
more from it a so at this stage of your
career when you're when you're looking
at like what you're putting down when
you're making albums when you're putting
together your music like what what
excites you the most about it um I'm a
huge fan of music in general so I get
just inspired off like production and
[ __ ] like that like the newest producers
and [ __ ] mm-hmm like cuz I like to go
out I like to enjoy myself
I like that fun so whatever is poppin
like at that that time whatever the
sound is whether it's West Coast
inspired or if it's down south inspired
I'm just interested in finding my own
way of doing what's new and what what my
fans would love for me because like as a
music person you want something new
every time you don't want the old [ __ ]
all the time you could go by that so I
just love creating and just coming up
with what's new you know what I mean
like I work with the newest producers I
work with the newest artists I work with
you know I mean I try to I try to make
my [ __ ] sound different every time I
always tell my engineer I'm like yo
let's [ __ ] with the [ __ ] sonically so it
don't sound the same as the last album
like alright come up with new ad-libs or
just different [ __ ] to just kind of keep
it fresh still do what people know me
for you know what I mean but it's like
just coming up with new ways of doing
that I get excited that's awesome here
mm-hmm I love it when someone loves what
they're doing and it comes out great
yeah thanks it's beautiful seeing it it
really is and that to me is one of the
most inspiring things that I get out of
any artist it's like hearing them talk
about their process right no I get I
always get jazzed up I love it it's
crazy for me because like there's
different ways to do what what I do like
I have so many ways like I could sit
there and just come up with some [ __ ]
like brand new or I have like this the
Oriole commercial with my son where it's
like there's a team of people who like
come up with what could be the best for
me and I just do that [ __ ] and then it
just goes crazy you know
I mean it's like see you again is one of
my biggest songs and that song I like
eight different people on it but I wrote
two verses that the person who made the
original song I wrote two verses for it
that they loved more than anybody else's
song I mean anybody else's so they gave
me the whole record and it ended up
being my host I mean one of my biggest
songs you know what I mean so it's like
the process of just like putting
yourself in the situation and just being
my alright cool that's work that's
beneficial as as beneficial as being you
know I mean a creative just okay I'm
gonna do what I do you know I mean
sometimes you got to step outside of
that and just use your talents it's like
being an actor or you know what I mean
like you just fill in that spot that
people need you in and I'm kind of at
that point in my career because I worked
so hard and grinded and done so many
things and come up with so many waves
and ideas that didn't exist before
now I could use other people's ideas and
just be myself and still and get you
know a really big effect and everybody
is happy beautiful yep dude you live in
the life - got it nailed
Elian graduation oh yeah I had a great
time talking to you - very nice thank
you that's it everybody
bye idea
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]